flowers to work for later is the
pink nevada i am a legal aid
when a little bit of me
here in southern nevada what do
you do we are a
non-profit organization we
help the community to provide
legal services such as immigration
custody  bankruptcy divorces we
help low-
income people and they qualify for our
services right
now with the coronavirus there has been to
you you can say that there has been an increase
in this need for resources quite a
lot of people became
unemployed and they need
legal help to be able to  solve their
situations many of the people
need help with immigration others
with divorces or bankruptcy
our organization has been
providing information and legal help I know
that right now the center is closed
but how are you offering
this help we have several ways to
help the community
The first is to call our office
directly.  nte that is the phone number
70 2 386 10 70 we also provide
free classes of legal information
on services such as immigration custody
eternity divorces and bankruptcies to be
able to register for these
classes people only have to send
an email to registration
at dot el  csn dot
tell me that due to the coronavirus pandemic right
now you are
offering these virtual classes because it
is so important that the community knows
about these classes
if the period of the pandemic our
office offered classes in person
we decided to adopt a new format to be
able to maintain  the rules of the
instance and at the same time for
providing people with
much needed legal information after the
class people can also
sign up for a free consultation
with one of our attorneys to
determine if we can give them a
free attorney as well  to help you
with your services now tell me
so how do these classes work
when they start
it costs me money the houses are
completely free right now we are
in the summer the summer classes the
classes started on May 30 and run
until July 31 for example the
immigration classes are given on Thursdays
every other  Pérez at 9 in the morning
is very easy, as I told you, you just
have to register by
email or call our office at
70 286 10 70 to be able to register for
these classes and get the
legal information you need and through them they
are also talking about  bankruptcy divorce and
other issues for banking the classes
stay in peace
the Spanish would be immigration divorce
custody and bankruptcy
tell me what message you have for the
community why it is so important to
grab or take from these resources that
your center is offering to these
people who do not have  the resources to be
able to pay for a lawyer and organizations
like lewis admitted nothing can
help the provider  Make the services
completely free
if you only need legal information
to be able to attend the classes if you
need more in-depth services is
when we can give you a
free lawyer so that they can
help you with any of those services